[Music]
toroids are one of the most bizarre
corners of the POI world
but what if I told you they had the
potential to help save your shoulders
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to talk about a weird
curiosity of toroids that I stumbled
across a couple years ago and why it
might have some relevance to those of
you who are fighting shoulder injuries
but before we dive in I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinski and Becca beklonen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
all right so I have done a bunch of
videos on my channel now outlining
different techniques for creating
toroids but this in particular is a use
for toroids that didn't exist when I
first started doing them it's something
I came across accidentally actually
there's a way that you can switch timing
and direction using toroids in a way
that doesn't put as much wear and tear
on your shoulders as you do when you're
doing stalls now granted I need to say
up front this is not going to save you
from all shoulder injuries but it does
carry a lot of potential within it so
let's take a look at what normally
happens when we change timing and
Direction with our POI so normally when
I want to switch back and forth between
say split Time same direction and
together opposites I need to insert
either a stall or a pendulum basically
some kind of zero point that's going to
give me access to be able to change the
direction that the POI are spinning in
now whenever we perform stalls we by
default are kind of absorbing a lot of
the momentum of the POI into our arms
and shoulders I don't know about you all
but especially when I'm doing really
rapid stalls back and forth I can
definitely feel the impact up in here
shoulder injuries of course are
relatively common thing in the POI world
and there's something that have stopped
a lot of people's careers so I
definitely was interested when I
recognized that there was a different
way to change timing and direction that
spectacularly does not require putting
the same strain on our shoulders so let
me show you what I'm talking about here
as I'm spinning my POI clockwise in wall
plane here I'm going to go ahead and
switch it over to working in a
horizontal plane now notice that the way
I'm doing this is I'm using a plane Bend
rather than a plane break to get there
this is important when I do this using a
plane Bend I'm keeping the natural
momentum of the POI there I'm just
redirecting it now from here I have the
option to drop that POI down behind me
and you'll note notice the direction of
the POI relative to me seems to have
changed since it was in front of me
rather than being clockwise relative to
me it is now counterclockwise relative
to me if I bend the POI back over in
front of myself guess what I've
accomplished a direction change with the
POI by using its own momentum to change
the direction of it let me show you this
from the side here because I think it's
kind of difficult to grasp what I'm
talking about I'll also throw on some
Trails here so you can see what's going
on so from right here I'm going to go
ahead and let the momentum of the POI
guide it straight out when it's at the
top of its Arc now I'm going to go ahead
and let it drop when it's over back
behind me and use a regular old plane
brand and Cross Point to bring it over
in front of me so basically what I'm
doing here is I'm moving the POI through
three different plane orientations and
really rapid succession and the fact
that it's an odd number of plane
orientations means that inevitably in
the process I'm changing the direction
the POI is spinning in as well but wait
you say does that actually qualify as a
toroid and actually yes yes it does what
I'm doing is a different version of the
three-pointed toroid triangle you'll
note back in the tutorial where I broke
down what exactly an antiben toroid is I
pointed out that whenever we perform a
toroid with an odd number of points and
of course the toroid triangle being one
of them we wind up switching the
direction of the POI as well look at
this from the side it's basically
identical to the pattern that I just
showed you it's just that I happen to be
repeating it instead of stopping it so
why is this a big deal basically because
if I'm just redirecting the momentum of
the POI it doesn't have the same kind of
wear and tear on my shoulders as when
I'm performing a stall and having to
absorb all the momentum in the POI if I
just redirect it all I'm doing is gently
pushing it in a New Direction and that
saves a lot of wear and tear in my
shoulders so let me show you a
demonstration of this I can be spinning
the POI in split Time same direction and
then decide I'm going to switch it up
and look at that that happens so fast
and so slick it barely registered
likewise I can switch back and again
I've managed to make a timing and
Direction change that is nearly
invisible number one and number two it's
barely putting any kind of effort on my
shoulders in order to make it happen let
me show you that from the side here so
I'm spinning around in Split Time same
direction and when I want to I can go
ahead and whoop switch it around into
split time opposites again I can switch
it around and bring myself into split
Time same direction quick and easy the
one and only risk here is that there's a
slight possibility that you might get
your hand underneath your shoulder which
can lead to shoulder injuries but at the
same time this is the kind of movement
that I think you can very easily do
without making that risk happen so this
is the kind of thing that we're going to
want to drill with each hand going each
Direction so with the right hand I'm
spinning it clockwise and I can very
very easily shift it into spinning
counterclockwise relative to me from
counterclockwise I can likewise go back
into clockwise interestingly enough you
can think of there being a shape that is
underneath your shoulder and a shape
that's over your shoulder so as I'm
spending the POI clockwise here I can do
the under the shoulder shape or I can do
the over the shoulder shape like so each
of these things is an option for me
depending upon how much wear and tear I
want to put on my shoulders and where
exactly I want to do the transition
likewise we want to practice doing these
exact same things with the left hand
over on the left hand side so I know
this looks a little bit weird but try it
out for yourself it also feels really
smooth from where I'm sitting it's a
type of transition that I was not
expecting that I also have to say just
does some pretty amazing things both
visually as well as physically so I'd
love to see more people out there
playing with it did you get anything out
of this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help the channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you all so very much for your very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you would like to become one you can
do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to check out some of my other
videos on toroids and why wouldn't you
I'm going to go ahead and include a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you might
like this top video here based upon your
past viewing habits so maybe give that a
look as well thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
peace